[موسيقى]
الى عام جديد يخلق الله فيه ما لا نعلم
نعبر معا ونعبر عما يزول في خواطركم عن
رغيف خبز يصغر حقن دواء ان تفرغ ودجاج
عربي يؤكل حتى اخمص قدميه عن جامعه لا
تنفع وساكن لا يسمع وشيخ لا يخشع وحاكم لا
يشبع عن نجوم تبيع الاوطان واصفاد تقيد
النجوم عن جواز سفر ممنوع عن حلو من بغض
مقطوع النابغه من قومه منزوع وطاغيه على
الرؤوس مرفوع
انا رجل لا يريح ولا يستريح يقول نزار
قباني فلا تصحبيني على الطرق المعتمه
فشعريه مدان ودثريه مدان ودربي الطبيعيه
بين القصيده والمحكمه
يشرفني انني ما قبلت وساما فان الذي يمنح
الاوسمه ولم اكوا بوقا لاي نظام فشعر يا
فوق فوق الممالك والانظمه الى العناوين
بين ارجل الدجاج وطبول المطبلين ضاعت
العملات العربيه في اوراق المنجمين
بين كبير كهانه صغير يقتحم الاقصى
والاعلام الغربي يصف غارته بالسياره
جماعه الاخوان اليهود منظمه جديده تولد في
برنامج تلفزيوني
لماذا لا يستطيع المعارضون السوريون اي
يتصالحوا مع الاسد
اعلام اوروبي وفاه البابا بين دكتور الذي
اغضب المسلمين وطالته فضائح اغتصاب
الاطفال
رمضان قديروف يتنازل عن رئاسه روسيا لصالح
فلاديمير بوتين
حسابات من مانيلا تضع الاعجابات لقيس سعيد
فهل سيترشحوا لرئاسه الفلبين
[موسيقى]
مرحبا وكل عام وانتم بخير الشيطان
والسلطان والسرطان ثلاثه عوامل اساسيه في
العبور الى القبور الشيطان يزين الفساد
للعباد وبعض السلطان يفسد زينه الحياه
مقاومتهما ليست سهله ابدا اما السرطان
الذي فرق الجماعات والاحبه فنفتتح السنه
الجديده بشرا وامل كبير بقرب وضع العلماء
حدا له
روبرتغلين مواطن بريطاني قيل له انه لا
يعيش لاكثر من سنه بسبب اصابته بسرطان
القنوات الصفراويه
لكنه وبحسب صحيفه
قبل عرض شركه متخصصه بالخضوع لتجربه طبيه
على دواء لم يعلن عنه رسميا بعد لكونه قيد
الاختبار
والمفاجاه كانت بان جسد روبرت قد اصبح
خاليا تماما من السرطان
روبرتغلين ذهب الى الاطباء فتلك سنه
العلاج ولم يذهب الى العرافين فذلك مسلك
المجانين يروى ان نستالين اعدم عرافه
الدعم معرفته بالمستقبل بانه لم يعرف انه
ارسل اليه من يقتله هذا بالنسبه لامام
الملحدين السليم اما سيد الرسل الله محمد
عليه الصلاه والسلام فقط قال من اتى كاهنا
فصدقه بما يقول فقد كفر بما انزل على محمد
رواه ابو هريره
اخبار وابورصه العمله المحليه في مصر وعده
دول عربيه اخرى تشغل الان الناس من يستفتى
في هذا الموضوع هم ندره من المتخصصين
المتعوب عليهم كثير عمرو اديب ولطمنه
المصريين اتى بمنجما برازه خبير التاروك
لتعلن عن تعافي الجنيه بعد ثلاث اشارات
تقولوا لها الكراتين كذبه كده وشوفي لي
الجنيه في 20 23 اوضعه ايه صحته عامله
ازاي
الكبير المصري 23
طيب
هيعاني الجنيه المصري ولكن يمكن في الفتره
الاولى يا عمرو الفتره الاولى
ممكن اول ثلاث شهور من السنه بعد كده
فتره راحه فتره ارتياح الهدنه اللي انا
قلت لك عليها هيستقر وضعه
مايك فرقت معه على شهر معرفه الترول
المصريه
فالليره اللبنانيه ستستعيد شيئا من
عافيتها بل سينهار الدولار الامريكي
امامها خلال اربعه اشهر معلق يقول هؤلاء
اما ان يسلم وزارات الماليه في الدول
العربيه واما ان يلقى بهم وبما يروج لهم
في السجون بتهمه الدجل والتضليل اخر شيء
اخر محطه
بتاع الكهرباء
هيكون فيه رئيس تتنظم الامور كلها من بعد
خطه كبيره قبل ما يصير في رئيس جدلا وصف
بالسخيف احتل كل المساحه رجل الاعمال نجيب
سويرس ماذا بعض المذيعين مشاركا في اتهام
لهم بالتطبيل للحكومات المتعاقبه فجاءت
بعض ردودهم عليه بانه هو مطبل ايضا لكنه
استفاده اكثر منه يعني لم يختلفوا على
المبدا بل على قيمه الاجره
الطبول غطت على الرجول فبعد تسونامي
السخريه من ترويجه مؤسسات رسميه لاهميه
اكل ارجل الدجاج المحمره والمحمصه وزاره
التموين تتدخل وتدافع عن رجول الفراخ اللي
ضايع حقها ببلادنا في نصين تضعها على
موائدها
طيب اذا كانت الصين تاكل الكلاب والفئران
والصراصير ايضا هل نبدا بتخزينها
قويه
كبيره جدا
ومن ضمن الاطباء الغاليه جدا جدا فلسطين
والمهمه لما تحتويه من ماده جيلاتينيه لها
علاج الام الظهر والكلام ده كله بس طبعا
ده مش اختصاص عشان اتكلم به استفاده عن
كده افضل طريقه للترويج لاكل ارجل الدجاج
هي يتناولها المروجون على الشاشات كل مساء
ولا باس الى جانبها بحسائي ريش الدجاج
وفاء مكي ممثله مصريه معتزله قصرا مش
لاقيه حتى رجول فراخ
لسه قعدت لما ادور على جنايات عشان اجيب
كيس عيش ب 5 جنيه انا فنانه وما عنديش
شغلانه ثانيه غير كده وبجري على ابني قلت
قبل كده يتيم وعلى ام مريضه بالكانسر وعلى
حاجات كثيره قوي انا ما عنديش شغلانه
ثانيه
لعبت ادواره في مسلسلات مشهوره لا تجد ما
تطعم به عيالها منذ اسابيع
اجازه في اللغه العربيه
المسلسل
شرقيات ثم الاستاذ محمد الشريان واشتغلت
مسرح حلب انا ماني زعلان على حالي انا
بزعل على اولادي
انا عندي الكبير ما هو توحد
فتح باب البيت وطلع من البيت ومزيق الباب
بعد عضيمين الضمير لما قدر الظرف الي نحن
في فتح الباب او دخل سرق جورتين وطلع يعني
كانت فاضيه والمركبه كانت مليانه المشكله
انا صار لي شهر في بيتي بلا اكل يقولون
الحاجه
كل التوقعات على حبات القمح المتناثره من
حموله الشاحنات العابره تعيش اسر في احياء
هامشيه من الوقط طحنها الفقر
على قارعه هذه الطريق الرابطه بين ميناء
واكشوط ووسط المدينه تتقفى الدماني اثار
شاحنات محمله بالقمح املا في التقاط بقايا
ما تناثر من حمولتها على الارض
تقضي يومها في غرب التي معلقه من حبوب بين
الرمل والحجاره فهي كل ما تعول عليه في
تامين قوتها وعائلتها منذ سنين تكمل عائشه
ما بداته رفيقه دربها لتحول الفتات الى
منتوج قابل للبيع يساعدهن في مواجهتها هذه
الظروف
[موسيقى]
اتمار بين كبير شاب نشا على الارهاب يقول
الفلسطينيون فهو انضم الى العصابات
المسلحه للمستوطنين قبل بلوغه سن الرشد في
حضره الفكر المتطرف للحخام مايركانا بن
كفير عين وزيرا للامن القومي الاسرائيلي
واختصارا لوزير امن قومي واقي هذا الواقي
العنصري نسي اصله العربيه العراقي ورفع
لواء التطرف الديني ضد المسلمين
والمسيحيين فنفذ اقتحاما للمسجد الاقصى
المبارك كدفعه الاولى على حسابي وعوده
الانتخابيه
واصبحت واقعا هذه هي التوترات التي كان من
المنتظر ان تحدث بعد تشكيل حكومه
الاسرائيليه الاكثر تشددا في تاريخ
اسرائيل برئاسه اليمني المتطرف بنيامين
نتنياهو التوترات بدات بقت حمي باحات
المسجد نقصى على يدي اثمار بن غفير زعيم
الصهيونيه الدينيه المتطرفه وهو ليس لق
اقتحم الاول للاقصى على يد بن غفير بل
كرره مرارا في الماضي بصفته الشخصيه ثم
بصفته نائبا في الكنيست وها هي المراه
الاولى بصفته وزيرا
على المسجد الاقصى بما يعنيه لكل مقر
بالشهادتين حول العالم
فكيف يتبين للاعلام الغربي ان الواقي بن
كبير قام بزياره للمسجد الاقصى وهل ان اهل
المسجد دعوه لزيارته وهل هناك من يرضى
اصلا بزيارته وهل الزيارات تتم عاده مع
جيش مدججش وهل تعتبروا اوروبا والغرب
عموما ان جيش روسيا يقوم الان بزياره الى
اوكرانيا ام انه معتبروه غزوا عسكريا
المشكله الاكبر هي ان بعض الصحفيين العرب
وقعوا في فخ المصطلحات المتسلله فقاموا
بعمليات نسخ لصق عن بعض الوكالات الانباء
الغربيه وصار الاقتحام زياره ونسخ مسخا
واللصق مسقا الحكومه الاسرائيليه وغاضبه
من احاله الامم المتحده طلبا الى محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه للنظر في قانونيه
المستوطنات المحتله
نتنياهو يخرجوا حتى على اللياقات ابناء
الشوارع فيصف قرار الامم المتحده بالحقيقه
غضب الاسرائيلي وخطوات عقابيه مرتقبه من
قبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه بعد تقديم
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده طلبا لمحكمه
الجنايات الدوليه للنظر في قانونيه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد ضفه الغربيه
مرارا الامميه بالحقير الاسرائيليون نصبوا
على راس البرلمانهم مثليا متزوجا من رجل
سابقه
لامي
ر احول مثليا للجنس رئيسا للكنيست في
حكومه اسرائيل السابعه والثلاثين عذراء
رئيس الحكومه على مجهوده لاصل لهذا المنصب
ولكل الذين شجعوني
نعم ههه
جماعه الاخوان اليهود منظمه جديده وهميه
طبعا حتى الان ولدت في برنامج تلفزيوني
ليتبادل محلي الان يساري ويميني الاتهامات
بان كلا منهما اخوانجي في واحد من اندرياس
[موسيقى]
ان يعني تسيطر الشريعه اليهوديه على ما
يحدث في البلاد ولكن هذه تكون نهايه دوله
اسرائيل كما عرفناهم
[موسيقى]
ستخدم الفلسطينيين فلا باس باستئنافها
علما ان هذه هي حجه جميع المطبعين الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان استقبل سفيره
اسرائيل الجديده في انقره بخطن ثابته صارت
السفيره الاسرائيليه الجديده في تركيا صوب
الرئيس التركي في قصره بانقره سلمته اوراق
اعتمادها بعد سنوات من القطيعه
الدبلوماسيه لتفتح صفحه جديده في علاقات
تركيا واسرائيل تطور ياتي كجزء من الصوره
الكليه التي تظهر ان انقره باتت تغير
سياستها الخارجيه بالعام 2011 حضر رجب طيب
اردوغان وكان انا ذكر رئيسا للوز تركيا
حذر النظام السوري من مغبه القيام بمهجره
حماه ثانيه اما ولم يكتفي النظام بحسب
المعارضه بمنزره حماه ثانيه او ثالثه او
رابعه بل اوقف العداد على مجازره تقف
تركيا اليوم على مشاري في مطالبه الضحايا
بالمصالحه مع الجلاد بدون محكمه او
محاكمات يعلق معارضون سوريون بعد لقاء
موسكو الوزاري الروسي التركي السوري الذي
وصفه المشاركون بالايجابيه والبناء يجري
ذلك على واقعه هتافات في ارياف في حلب
وادلب تقول سمع صوتك لتركيا نحن اصحاب
القضيه مش انتم
سمع صوتك الليله يا تركيه
او نح
ناق
لا استطيع ان صالح
لم يخرج والضحيه لم تدفن والمهجر ولم يعد
والدمعه لم تجف لا استطيع ان يصالح لانه
وحشيه الرئيس لم تتغير ولكن نفترض جدلا
انني ساصالح افترض جدلا انني سانسى
المجازر افترض جدلا انني استطيع ان انسى
ان الرئيس قد قتل والدي واعدم اخي الاول
واخي الثاني افترض جدلا انني قادر على
انسى لما صالح لما اعطيك فرصه اخرى
[موسيقى]
البابا بين ايديكتوس السادس عشر ذكرت
وفاته هذا الاسبوع عن 95 عاما بمحطات
مختلفه طبعه رحلته الكهنوتيه التي توجه
باعتلائه سده الفاتيكان ثم الاستيقاله
بدعي التقدم في العمر مشهد البابا
بنديكتوس السادس عشر وهو يودع الكنادل في
عام 2013 ويغادر الفاتيكان بطائره مروحيه
دخل التاريخ فلم تشهد الكنيسه منذ العصور
الوسطى استقاله اي حبل اعظم بالعام 2006
اعتبرت مراجع دينيه انه كاد ان يتسبب
بفتته بين المسلمين والمسيحيين عندما اساء
للدين الاسلامي ولرسول الله محمد عليه
الصلاه والسلام حتى ان صحيفه الرياض
السعوديه عن ولد في حينه مقارنه بينما
وصفته بتعصبه بين الدكتور وسماحه سلفه
زومبي 2 او يوحنا بولس الثاني قالت
الاسلام تحت النار موجه غضب في العالم
الاسلامي واتهامات للباب بالوقاحه والجهل
في عام 2006 شهد العالم الاسلامي موجه غضب
عارمه اثر محاضره له في جامعه غتسبون
الالمانيه وصف فيها الاسلام بانه دين عنف
مع اقتباس لحوار جرى بين امبراطور بيزنطي
ومثقف فارسي بحسب تقارير الاعلام الغربي
كانديكتوس محافظا ايضا حين العلاقات مع
المذاهب المسيحيه الاخرى
كالارثوذكسيه
والبروتستانتيه كان يعرف عنه انه كان
محافظا في الخلافات حول المسائل الفقهيه
وقضايا الاصلاح كدول المراه او العلاقه مع
الطوائف المسيحيه الاخرى من القضايا التي
لاحقه الباب بينكتوس حتى بعد تقاعده بحسب
وسائله اعلام اوروبيه رسميه فضائح قصابصه
كاثوليك باعتداءات جنسيه على اطفال ورغم
وضعه الصحى السيء وجهت اليه اتهامات خطيره
في يناير 2020 اذا خلص تقرير للجنه مستقله
ان بيريديكتوس كان على علم بدعاءات
الاعتداءات الجنسيه ضد قساوسه الكنيسه في
ابرشيته خلال فتره عمله كرئيس اسقيفه
ميونخ اعلن الرئيس السوداني رمضان قادرون
عن قبوله اعتذار الفاتيكان من جمهوريه
الشيشان بعد تصريحات للبابا فرنسيس ادعى
فيها ان المقاتلين الشيشان هم الاكثر قصوه
في اوكرانيا في تلمي حاتم اعتبرها البعض
طائفيه الرئيس قديروف ذكر البابا بانه لا
يتكلم باسمه الشخصي وحذر الجميع من المس
بالمشاعر
السباعي تجاري بتاع السوداء
في اثناء النويه
[تصفيق]
عن رئاسه روسيا لصالح بوتين القوي الحكيم
الموهوب والصادق النزيح
بكره
امم طبعا
[موسيقى]
لماذا يضعون الاعجابات على خطاباته
المنشوره باللغه العربيه على الموقع
الرسمي لرئاسه الجمهوريه التونسيه علما ان
كثيرا من العرب يصعب عليهم فهموا خطابات
الرئيس السعيد
اتهمت تحالفه المعارضه الرئيسي في تونس
سلطه الرئيس سعيد باستخدام القضاء لاغراض
سياسيه وذلك بعد الاستدعاء بالمثول
القضائي لقيادات في جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
سلطات سعيد لم تكتفي بالتونسيين بل وسعت
نشاطها واعتقلت المقرئ الكويتيه الشهير
محمود الرفاعي بتهمه الارهاب بعد تنظيمه
مسابقه للاطفال لتحفيظ القران الكريم في
تونس ثم افرجت عنه لاحقا بعد التدخل من
وزاره الخارجيه الكويتيه
واخيرا نعرض لكم معايده خاصه من رئيس تونس
قيس سعيد اتوجه اليكم في كل مكان
داخله ترابي وطننا العزيز
من اقصى ناقصه في الشمال الى اخرين ذره
حبل
ذره
في الجنوب كل عام وانتم بخير
[موسيقى]
ختاما ذكرتنا قصه احراج الشاعر الليبي
الشاب عبد السلام سعيد ابو حجر هذا
الاسبوع لجنه الحكم لبرنامج امير الشعراء
في احدى القنوات التلفزيونيه الاماراتيه
عندما خطا كبير الحكام صحيح لسان الشاعر
الشاب ذكرتنا بحكايه تعود الى اربعينيات
القرن الماضي حين استقدم معهد المصري
الاستاذ الهنديه مجيدا للغه العربيه
وكان لا يتكلمها الا بالفصحى فهله حديث
الطلاب بالعاميه فضلا عن اخطائهم اللغويه
الكثيره اذا كتبوا او تكلموا قرر ايون هي
تعاقده ويعود الى بلاده فساله عميد المعهد
حيث تسيبنا ليه احنا زعلناك في حاجه
فاجابه كلها لكنني وبصراحه اخاف بينكم على
العربيه الله عليك رد العميل طب ما في
الجراج عربيتك حطها في الموقع في الباركنج
فسافر الاستاذ الهندي على اقرب طائره الى
اللقاء
ويعجبني في الذكريات
سخائها
لماذا سخاء
لان الذكر
اعرابي
انا المفعول به ياء المتكلم هنا مفعول به
انا المعجب وهي المعجبه
كيف يعني سخاء الذكرياتك انت الذي اعجبت
بالسخان
[موسيقى]